what the hell is that what the hell are
you wearing machine where's the case
okay thank you see the case what minor
upgrade from the Tony store oh this is
cool is it I've ever seen
hey youtubers it's Charlie we finally
get to share some footage so trailer
dropping tomorrow they're just gonna be
some quick notes in my top five
spider-man films there are actually
seven spider-man films that almost got
made though so I talked about those
extra ones too there is a new round of
the spider-man giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video make sure to
click that Bell to enable alerts so that
you don't miss out on anything so my
spider-man trailer video will post
really late tomorrow night in case you
guys didn't know they're gonna post it
super late so as long as you have alerts
on you will totally see it when it drops
so this is a version of the footage that
they showed up at Brazil Comic Con is
just like a slightly different version
because the trailer that they're
dropping is much bigger typically when
they show off Comic Con footage it's
much shorter it's much more jumbled up
but if you couldn't tell he's jumping
off the Washington Monument like he's on
a field trip with his class like there's
other people from his class there but
you can see how well Jon Favreau as
happy Hogan will work in this like he
has to babysit Tony Stark but they're
kind of like brothers because they're
almost the same age but then you see him
with the kid and he's just like I gotta
babysit the kid aw hell but this is the
briefcase that we saw in the behind the
scenes pictures I talked a little bit
about it when I broke down that Comic
Con footage and I'll link that video at
the end of this too but just get hype so
there's gonna be way more spider-man
footage that nobody has seen before
dropping tomorrow but let's rank our top
spider-man films there are actually a
couple spider-man films that you might
not know about that did not get made so
most of you know about Andrew Garfield
and Tobey Maguire era spider-man but
there were a couple really crazy
sounding spider-man movies that almost
got made by the same people that made
those Superman movies the ones that kind
of drove that franchise into the ground
but starting at the top you know
favorite spider-man movie of all time is
still spider-man 2 Tobey Maguire era
that is still one of the finest
superhero films of the modern era now I
know there's been a lot of superhero
movies since that came out so he got
knocked off the top perch for a long
time it was my favorite superhero movie
of all time
just really well made with a really
amazing villain performance from Doctor
Octopus but it's second favorite
spider-man film is the first Tobey
Maguire film yes I think that Bow
the tobey maguire films at least the
first two are better than the Andrew
Garfield films so that first spider-man
film sort of rode the wave of really
hopeful awesome superhero films it came
out after Bryan Singer's x-men film that
in my mind was the beginning of really
good big blockbuster superhero films the
Bryan Singer film then Spiderman came
right after that it was like a one-two
punch it's like oh my god
spider-man what an amazing character
this is gonna be so awesome but a lot of
people felt like it was held back by
Tobey Maguire's moppy performance he
wasn't motormouth Peter Parker that Tom
Holland is doing right now and you
really didn't get much of a chance to
see him as a teenager like he grew up
really fast in that franchise especially
in that first spider-man movie but
credit where credit is due it gave us
that classic Danny Elfman spider-man
theme that became so iconic the Danny
Elfman theme is kind of like the John
Williams Superman theme it just became
this instant classic but the funny thing
about spider-man 2 is that they used a
Nickelback song to promote one of the
trailers and Nickelback is now used in
some places as punishment for criminals
and just for reference though Michael
Giacchino is scoring spider-man
homecoming so he'll be the person to
write the new hopefully iconic
spider-man theme song but number three
was the amazing spider-man which I felt
like was an interesting take on the
character it was really like the Tobey
Maguire era spider-man done with better
technology in slightly different
characters they opted for gwen stacy
instead of mary jane but i feel like it
was held back a little just by the fact
that they had rebooted the spider-man
franchise so quickly and done the almost
exact same story they did the origin
story again even though they kind of
messed around a little bit with the
villains but it was still a really
entertaining film it was still a lot of
fun to watch but I feel like Andrew
Garfield you know not true Peter Parker
still kind of in the way that Tobey
Maguire hits some of the bases but just
didn't ever quite encapsulate comic book
Peter Parker so number four amazing
spider-man 2 we just kind of fell apart
as a film just a little overstuffed
because they were trying to create their
spider-man Cinematic Universe before the
big fallout at Sony before
they made the Marvel deal so there were
a lot of good things in that movie but I
feel like they kind of got lost in the
shuffle just because it got so crazy in
the film fell apart in the third act so
like one of my favorite things from that
film was Jamie Foxx's character before
they kind of pushed him over the ledge
of super crazy like there was a note
from Kevin Feige
like he gave them notes on amazing
spider-man 2 and one of them said Jamie
Foxx is doing some really amazing stuff
but we probably don't need to go inside
his apartment it makes him seem too
crazy but sure enough they left it in
the movie and he started to seem just
completely batshit crazy but then as you
probably guess my number 5 pick is
spider-man 3 the Tobey Maguire film
least-favorite spider-man film that was
actually released in theaters just
because it suffered from the exact same
problems is amazing spider-man 2 but it
didn't have a really great Jamie Foxx
performance the villains weren't quite
as good I did not like Topher Grace even
though I loved the idea that they were
trying to work venom into the Canon and
it just started to fall apart
under its own weight you know same
problem of hey this is the third movie
so we got to make it bigger we got to
stuff more characters in there without
worrying about how it was all gonna fall
apart under its own weight so now that
we have a new Spider Man film coming out
I'm gonna have to rewatch all those it's
been a long time since I've watched some
of those spider-man movies but if you
think a couple of those were bad movies
there was a canon films version of a
Spider Man movie that was in development
Bob Hoskins was going to be Uncle Ben
Tom Cruise was going to be a
college-aged spider-man now I know
you're like wait a minute Tom Cruise is
like in his 50s now when was this movie
gonna be made he was actually closer to
1990 because this was after that last
cannon films Superman film which was in
the late 80s so they did all this
development work Doctor Octopus was
going to be the villain but they
included all these non-canonical things
as you can imagine the way they treated
the Superman franchise it was going to
be the same deal for the spider-man
franchise so it would have been a bit of
a nightmare
luckily Tom Cruise opted not to do it so
it all fell apart in the Wrights went
elsewhere but it is much of a be
spider-man movie Horror Show is that
would have been the one sad thing is
that Stan Lee at
the time wanted to play jay jonah
Jameson himself so what might have been
I mean he found his way into all the
Marvel movies one way or another through
his cameos so we got there eventually
but then later James Cameron picked up
the option and then you had like James
Cameron era spider-man but he wanted to
do the story of how Gwen Stacy died that
they essentially did an amazing
spider-man 2 that was gonna be a
slightly more hardcore version you've
seen a lot of James Cameron films so
this was post aliens 1990s era James
Cameron it would have been like a really
big blockbuster but also it would have
been super weird like he wanted Edward
Furlong for Peter Parker which would
have just completely thrown me out of
the movie but the really cool thing is
that Lance Henriksen would have been his
Green Goblin just you know Lance
Henriksen been in so many James Cameron
films so at that time it would have
totally made sense but you have to
imagine like a slightly more serious
version of Green Goblin than say like
Willem Dafoe who played it extra crazy
other people on this list though it gets
even more crazy
drew Barrymore is gwen stacy remember
this is about the death of Gwen Stacy
and Leonardo DiCaprio is Harry Osborn
now this is still pre Titanic Leonardo
DiCaprio so he was a big star but not
nearly as big as he is today so let me
know in the comments what is your
favorite spider-man movie so far
assuming we haven't seen spider-man
homecoming yet and do you think that
spider-man homecoming will be your new
favorite after you see it we can't
really say how good it's going to be
just because we haven't seen the whole
movie yet but we have seen Tom Hollands
version of Peter Parker so I'll say just
seeing his performance and civil war in
this trailer footage he seems like a
much more true version of the character
but they're doing the character in a way
that they haven't done him before just
keeping him a teenage superhero trying
to live in this bigger Avengers world
with all the stuff that's been happening
so far so I'm just so happy with the way
things have gone down the last couple of
years with the Sony Marvel deal and it
gives me a lot of hope for Fantastic
Four other superhero franchises like the
x-men films so the only bummer about the
x-men stuff is that Kevin Feige said
that they are at an impasse with Fox
there is no deal that's going to be made
anytime soon
that but when people ask him about that
he's like ya know nothing has changed
you know I see them every once in a
while because he was an executive
producer on Bryan Singer's first x-men
film so he's friends with all those Fox
people but on a business level like they
all have boards of directors an army of
lawyers and suits that are just shaking
their heads nope no deal not gonna do it
so Deadpool is gonna be really awesome
hopefully they can start making some
really awesome x-men films - because if
Sony can get their [ __ ] together and do
this Marvel stuff then so can Fox but
what's gonna happen is is that after I
post my spider-man trailer video I will
do a Q&A that next day so be sure to
leave all your spider-man questions
Avengers questions infinity war anything
that you guys want me to talk about so
later tonight arrow finale I know a lot
of you are asking for an agents of
shield video I'll do that as soon as
possible
so so much craziness hopefully you guys
are on break from school or you get some
time off from work but it's gonna be
nuts so I'll be doing a ton of
spider-man videos in the next couple of
weeks it's gonna be a lot of fun well
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to learn all about carnage
and you can click here for last night's
flash finale video thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you